in the future you could be building your
own smartphone or tablet just like this
slotting pieces together like Lego even
a six year old can make this simple
computer and it's from Kanno
they hope to inspire a new generation
and make the UK a world leader in
technology innovation when you look at
the way a two-year-old baby plays with
an iPad it really looks like a magic
because they basically swipe a finger
and they do anything they want they can
change the screens they can play a game
but when you when you look deep into it
they have no idea how it actually
operates what better way to get people
learning about computers and how they
work than to make it fun like a game and
considering experts say that we'll need
1 million more people to work in the
tech sector in the next decade the UK
government's plan to change the
curriculum in schools is a good place to
start
when you dress something up as a as a
kiddy product and you tell them that
it's good for them it suddenly becomes
like broccoli or Brussels sprouts we
thought a kid you know take it out of
the box we don't have to be there it's
something that you play with the
experience you control and at the end of
it you know you can make any number of
things Apple co-founder Steve Wozniak
has backed them and they've raised close
to a million pounds to develop cannon a
little treasure chest with components
and cords and cables all very colorful
here we have the brain it's powered by
Raspberry Pi a credit card sized
computer that plugs into a keyboard to a
color code in order to get kids you know
visual cues red we use for power yellow
we use for video this SD card has you
know what we think is the world's most
simple fun yet you know still open
source and free operating system based
on Linux so and here we go a computer
comes to life on the screen the kit
doesn't come with the screen which may
put people off considering you can pick
up a supermarket tablet for very little
so we asked a tech entrepreneur who's
made millions while he thinks of canners
ances kind of done the old Apple model
which was take those apart
give it some brand in packaged it up
well focus on your your key users by
actually it's underpriced and I may get
shot for this it feels too cheap they
seem to be bringing added value
it's really important for us to kind of
find the sweet spot between what we're
providing and at what price because
we're trying to not just feel the
computer anyone can make but it means
when anyone can make it means that it's
also very affordable the team want to
make playing with a can o kit as fun as
plugging in a Playstation and if you've
been yearning to get your hands back on
pong it might be well worth the 79 pound
price tag